a Tatar of Jerusalem artichokes perch in
charvel butter crab with chicory and
hibiscus Daniel Achilles has been
awarded two Michelin stars for his
cuisine three points from fine schmekel
magazine and 18 from go Mego restaurant
guide kind stuff his restaurant in
Berlin seats just 35 people he funded it
without investors by taking out a bank
loan he sees the fact that he's now been
honored as 2014 chef of the year as
recognition for all his work matus
assistance is a cool of course it's
really a great honor it's clearly an
immense incentive and a boost and it
also feels like a lot of work does this
is a zippy I my daughter's his
restaurants name reflects his recipe for
success rice tov translates roughly as
pure material he uses only regional
products which he buys straight from the
producers themselves in today's delivery
fresh flounder this is awful I stand
fish Buddha unlovable some people might
think it's a kind of fish that doesn't
belong in old cuisine but I think it
does have a right to be there such an
outsider's I need a science festival
Achilles distinctive cuisine is down to
earth yet sophisticated and it's a hit
there are already 20 reservations for
today even early in the morning the
kitchen is already running at full tilt
but the tone isn't usually friendly
coins friendly but professional lilies
honestly without trying to curry favor
he's the best boss I've ever worked
worked at him cookery is daniel's
passion and it has been since his
childhood
this camp will be fun fun inhales later
Kenda you just came from inside me
everybody knows how it sometime during
your school yours the question comes up
of how you want to earn your money later
on all you want to feed your family or
pay for a flat-screen TV Owen Ted and I
decided when I was about 13 or 14 I'm
its mid-hudson filton after training as
a chef he worked at many well-known
german gourmet restaurants one of his
mentor's was fun amador known for his
molecular cuisine Spina and is this is
fun and it was very exciting very wild
time I picked up how to make all these
detailed molecular dishes and it was a
very exciting and in some ways a
defining time for me Jimmy's the whole
thing didn't give his otherwise inert
who's obviously updating in 2009
Achilles decided to go his own way
together with his girlfriend Sabine
edema he opened Rhine stuff in Berlin
it's open five days a week
his only relaxation is taking short
walks through the city center the fleet
is receiving a second I like taking
these walks and of course things that
happen along the way to work can be
extremely inspiring cas pidiendo in fact
agellius finds Berlin itself inspiring
in the past 10 years the German capital
has become something of a gourmet
stronghold no other German city has as
many Michelin stars to offer berlin now
boasts 52 * and 91 star restaurants this
culvert assist each bun stir liban I
think it's the most exciting lively and
pulsating gastronomic seen anywhere
mckissick mins especially this middle
segment it's developed in Berlin with
the cuisine is just anger a star or
about to get on or the courts forged and
the concepts are extremely exciting it
worked very very well and that's what
makes Berlin special when does estas was
Benigno smarter this blog takes a
quarter of an hour then it's back to the
kitchen arranging the food sending it
out and cooking more the chef of the
years working day can last up to 14
hours oh boy getting some rest is a nice
thought but right now I don't see it as
realistic with his new title comes
responsibility Daniel wants to defend
his reputation at any price but always
with down to earth cuisine whose
sophistication lies in its simplicity